here with more he's with the house
oversight committee James comr is with
us house ways and means committee
chairman Jason Smith and house Judiciary
Committee chairman Jim Jordan
Congressman comr I start with you
tonight your reaction to today's events
and of course your statement that went
out earlier today with Jim Jordan uh
that you that the hunter has defied a
lawful subpoena and you will now
initiate contempt of congress
proceedings and that Hunter will not be
provided special treatment because his
last name is
Biden well I've never seen such a
display of arrogance and entitlement as
I saw today when uh you had over a dozen
members of Congress in a committee room
waiting for Hunter Biden to appear uh
because he was lawfully subpoenaed uh
while we were there with staff who had
spent countless hours preparing
questions substantive questions uh at
the same time Hunter Biden goes out and
has a press conference and uh plays the
victim card defies a congressional
subpoena says he wants to tell his story
and then gets in a car and drives off I
think the American people saw that was a
publicity stunt that went bust we have
had a credible investigation that the
American people expect they want to know
what the bidens did to receive the tens
of millions of dollars from our enemies
around the world and we're going to
continue to pursue the truth and we're
doing it lawfully and by the
Constitution and today Hunter Biden got
into more trouble if that's even
possible by defying our lawful subpoena
and let's get your take Jim Jordan uh
because you along with Congressman comr
uh put out the statement about Hunter
failing to appear for the deposition and
are now initiating contempt of congress
proceedings um tell us what's going to
happen next well we'll do a report and
then we'll then we'll mark it up pass it
through the committee and then it'll go
to the Full House and I think those Sean
the big takeaways today were number one
every single Republican voted to move
forward with an impeachment an inquiry
and continue our oversight
responsibility every single one the
conventional wisdom all we can't get all
Republicans but a majority of the house
is now on record in support of the
investigation that we've been doing
second is what you said in your opening
line Joe Biden went from no involvement
to oh he participated in dinners and
meetings and phone calls but they were
just talking about the weather to today
Hunter Biden saying my father had no
Financial involvement that qualifier is
huge no Financial involed in the
business what a change we would have
loved to had Hunter Biden under oath in
a deposition the way these
investigations are supposed to work and
the first question we would ask him is
who's the big guy who's the big guy Mr
Biden the confidential human Source said
it's Joe Biden in the 1023 form your
partner said it's Joe Biden who's the
big guy and then what was on that call
that you made from Dubai at the request
of barisma to get help from DC when you
called your father what did you ask him
to do cuz we know what he went and did
what did you ask him to do on that phone
call those are two important questions
that I think the American people deserve
to know about and the facts about that's
what we would ask him if we had a chance
I hope we get a chance Jason Smith let's
talk about what you learned last week in
your committee the Ways and Means
Committee uh as it relates to pseudonim
emails uh that Joe Biden used I don't
think he was supposed to do that as a
part of the records act uh but he did
communicate communicate quite often with
Eric Sherwin who is the individual at
rosemon senica I believe that was in
charge of the finances he is the person
that Hunter himself would always ask oh
what account should we use to pay uh
dad's home repair bill on this in this
case or that case is that the
guy that's exactly right he's known as
being the architect of those 20 plus
Shell Shell companies that Hunter Biden
um and the bidens use to filter through
millions of dollars what those IRS
whistleblowers provide to our committee
last week
Sean is it stood stood in agreement with
what they've already provided of more
than a thousand Pages what those IRS
whistleblowers said in regards to the
prosecution that Hunter Biden should
face in the tax crimes of 2016 to 2019
what happened in California confirmed
everything with the IRS whistleblowers
whistleblowers alleged one thing that we
should be looking at Sean is that those
whistleblowers also stated how many
leads led to President Joe Biden but
they were stopped by the justice
department and that's what we need to be
looking into let me ask you Congressman
comr what do we know how much money can
you confirm that the Biden family took
in from China Romania Russia uh Ukraine
Kazakhstan and other countries how much
money are we talking about and can you
confirm that the 1023 form uh that we
had talks so often about uh that accused
Joe Biden of taking official action as
vice president in exchange for a family
benefit that would be Hunter's benefit
was that the barice MC
case yeah I can say this first of all we
found over $24 million that flowed into
those shell companies that Jason Smith
was referencing earlier uh we have no
idea what the bid did to receive the
money we know those shell companies
serve no purpose we've seen Bank emails
and we've seen suspicious activity
reports from banks that said they were
investment companies with no Investments
and uh companies with no known purposes
now we know that the 1023 form alleged
that they took a bribe uh this was in
conjunction with the barisma and uh one
thing that triggered the discovery of
the 1023 form Sean was the fact that the
uh people the whistleblowers that turned
over the 1023 form to Chuck Grassley
they knew about this 1023 form but
because the narrative had been all the
bishma thing was was Rudy gani and it
was fake news and Russian disinformation
they never paid any attention to it but
when the house oversight committee
started unveiling evidence in Romania
and China where the bidens were
receiving uh suspicious funds that were
being laundered through these various
bank accounts and various shell
companies those whistleblowers said
that's exactly what it said in the 1023
form about Ukraine that's why they came
forward the came forward because of our
evidence and and you can confirm that
you have discovered over 20 shell
companies but you see no real business
activity except the movement of money
from one account to another you confirm
that sir yes and that's what we wanted
hunter Biden to have an opportunity he
can explain if I miss misunderstanding
this he can tell us exactly what these
different companies did and you can
confirm that 10 family members Biden
family members were paid including
grandchildren and you can find no
evidence of any services rendered at at
all is that true sir that is true let me
ask you Jim Jordan we know that Joe
Biden has said that they never got any
money from China in the GMA interview
Hunter said pretty much the same thing
um when we talk about the what'sapp
message call uh and he says I'm I'm
sitting here with my father we don't
know why you didn't fulfill your
commitment between everybody that he
knows of my ability to hold a grudge you
will regret not fulfilling that
commitment uh my father and I are
sitting here waiting for you to call uh
is it true Jim Jordan that in fact $5
million was sent to one of those uh
companies if you will within a number of
days thereafter and was that another
example of of more money coming from an
oil conglomerate this one in China yeah
CFC the the Energy company in China
sends five 5 million after that that
phone call and and if I remember the
WhatsApp message it was between me and
the guy sitting beside me that have been
another question we' ask him who was the
guy sitting beside you who are you
referring to and that it seems pretty
obvious but we would have asked him that
that question and Sean back to your
other question we know what the business
was it was access to the brand Devon
Archer told us in July the brand is Joe
Biden so it was access to Joe Biden
because he has influence everyone with
common sense can see what was going on
here and the dinners and the phone calls
and the meetings with his Hunter Biden's
business partners and more importantly
the people he's doing business with like
Elena batarina the wealthiest woman in
all of Russia that anyone can see what's
going on here that's why we had every
single Republican vote today to move
move for further and farther with our
investigation to get these people in in
a timely fashion and get the facts for
the country yes or no exit question for
all of you uh Congressman Smith I'll
start with you is this now an
investigation about Joe Biden being
involved in what would be a bribery
scand Scandal a money laundering Scandal
and an influence pedaling
Scandal this has always Sean been an
investigation in regards to Joe Biden
the IRS whistleblowers when they came
forward they highlighted how the Justice
dep about those three issues though
that's what I'm asking
bribery influence could it be a
multitude of numerous items and we're
just continuing to follow the facts
James comr is that what these this is
about those three issues yes sir
Jim Jordan Final Answer Sean remember
it's the standard in the Constitution
bribery High crimes and misdemeanors and
typically with impeachment articles of
impeachment it's been bribery it's been
abuse of power it's been uh obstruction
of justice so those are the things that
we're looking at we want to get the
facts and then we'll make a
determination all right this is going to
get very interesting in the days weeks
and months ahead hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else